She sang, danced and moved audiences to tears.
Born in 1928, Shirley Temple was a film sensation by the age of six,...
...bringing her uplifting song and dance to a nation in the depths of The Depression.
She appeared in dozens of movies including "Little Miss Marker" and "Bright Eyes",...
...becoming the most popular movie star in America.
Her career slowed as she became a teen.
She had a few roles, and at 17, married the actor John Agar.
They were married for five years.
Her second marriage to Charles Black lasted until his death in 2005.
Retired from Hollywood, Shirley Temple Black made her mark as a diplomat.
In 1969, President Richard Nixon appointed her to the US delegation...
...to the United Nations General Assembly.
Under President Gerald Ford, she was US ambassador to Ghana,...
...and under President Reagan, US ambassador to Czechoslovakia...
...during the collapse of communism in 1989.
Hollywood honored Shirley Temple in 1935 with a special Oscar,...
...and the Screen Actors Guild gave her a Lifetime Achievement Award.
I have one piece of advice for those of you...
...who want to receive the Lifetime Achievement Award.
Start early.
President Bill Clinton recognized her work at the Kennedy Center in Washington in 1998.
From her childhood to the present day, Shirley has always been an ambassador...
...of what was best about America.
Shirley Temple Black was diagnosed with breast cancer...
...and underwent a mastectomy in 1972.
Afterwards, she worked to educate others about the disease.
She lived near San Francisco, where she died Monday night.
Mike O'Sullivan, VOA News, Los Angeles.